it's great to be joined on the program
today by Shane Dickson Cavanaugh who is
the staff reporter with The Oregonian in
Portland
Shane great to have you on first of all
thanks for your time hey thanks so much
for inviting me on your show today so
you've been working on this story which
involves university students from Saudi
Arabia who have faced criminal charges
in a number of different American states
this has also happened in Canada and
they've effectively disappeared and the
term disappeared can mean a couple of
different things it can be the good type
of disappearance or the bad type of
disappearance I guess depending on on
who exactly you are in the entire thing
how did this even first get on your
radar well we started with just one case
in particular that was a very big story
at the time here in Portland where a
Saudi national a college student here in
Portland was charged in the fatal
hit-and-run of a teenage girl in a sort
of popular part of Southeast Portland
the Saudi government ended up bailing
this individual out of jail posting
$100,000 so he could be out of jail
while he awaited trial and then weeks
before his trial he suddenly disappears
and this is a guy who was on house
arrest had an ankle monitor and
what-have-you and at the time of his
disappearance that was a pretty big deal
that a foreign national essentially
skipped bail or banished just weeks
before his trial fast forward a year in
some months and I had learned while
talking with a law enforcement source
that federal investigators believed that
the Saudi Arabian government actually
helped this individual
escape prosecution and essentially leave
Oregon and the United States and return
to Saudi Arabia and the circumstances of
his escape the details were pretty
remarkable
we learned that federal law enforcement
assert that a black SUV came to this
individuals house and picked him up
drove him out to sand and gravel yard in
East Portland
where he sliced his ankle monitor and
then drove off investigators believe
that the Saudi Arabian government likely
furnished this individual with an
illicit Passport since he didn't have
one and possibly got him out of the
country or North America on a private
plane so learning just about that one
case here in Portland was pretty
remarkable I mean just the details of it
and then we started looking into this a
bit more in Oregon to see could there
possibly be other cases like this and
within a few weeks we found four other
cases here in Oregon that fit the same
type of pattern specifically young men
students who were studying in the u.s.
from Saudi Arabia were on a scholarship
program from the Saudi government get
arrested and accused of very serious
crimes so in the first case we were
talking about vehicular manslaughter
fatal hit-and-run we're also looking at
rape possession of child pornography
felony DUI assaults all of these
individuals ended up disappearing before
their trials or in one case before one
individual completed his jail sentence
so let's just cross a couple of things
off the list if we can the US and Saudi
Arabia don't have an extradition treaty
and there's not even the remote
possibility that that's what's going on
here
well yes it's true that the US and Saudi
Arabia despite being long-standing
allies we consider Saudi Arabia an
important sort of partner in the Middle
East and obviously we trade the billions
with them a year manufacture arms and
send them over there you know they're
one of the world's largest producers of
oil but we do not have an extradition
treaty with Saudi Arabia which means if
a Saudi citizen here in the US is
accused of a serious crime or any crime
ends up leaving the US and return to
Saudi Arabia the Saudi Arabian
government is not going to turn one of
these individuals back over to the u.s.
to face prosecution I mean there's a
number of countries around the world
that the US doesn't share an extradition
treaty with in a number in the Gulf
region
but for an ally and you know the
considered partner as big as Saudi
Arabia it's a little bit unusual that we
don't have an extradition treaty with
them so when we talk about the the sort
of disappearance obviously you've
pointed out the ways in which Saudi
authorities in the United States might
be involved but would this be possible
without some involvement or at least
indifference from American law
enforcement I mean that's a really good
question and it's obviously one we've
been asking since we've started looking
into this matter and at this point in
time it's not really known what role the
US has had if any in facilitating the
departure of some of these students and
you know I was talking about the cases
here in Oregon and I it's worth
mentioning that since finding the five
cases in Oregon we've started looking
around the US and in Canada to see if
this was happening in other places and
so far we've found cases like these in
seven other states and as well as Canada
and so you know it seems to be a pattern
that's been going on for decades we've
have traced a manslaughter case back to
1988 in Ohio with this exact same thing
happened and prosecutors there I talked
to people who involved in this case
thirty years ago and they you know very
directly he stated they believed that
the Saudi Arabian government helped
facilitate this individuals escape but
in terms of what the u.s. involvement
has been that's not really known but I
mean I think the other sort of question
that we're trying to find the answer to
is what has the US government known and
for how long
because it seems very unlikely that
somebody within the FBI the State
Department the Department of Justice
would not have known about a number of
these you know individuals for nationals
accused of serious crimes essentially
vanished vanishing without a trace I'm
guessing the answer to this next
question is sort of obvious because
they are saudis studying in the united
states but are we talking all about rich
families here people with access to
money wealthy people you know that's a
that's a question that gets that's been
asked a lot since we've been reporting
on these cases and you know it wouldn't
be surprising to think that most of
these kids came from sort of
well-connected or affluent families in
Saudi Arabia
however I'll point out that the King
Abdullah scholarship program which is
sent hundreds of thousands of Saudi
students to the u.s. to study in the
last 15 years or so or actually more
about 13 years it's been hundreds of
thousands of people and not all of them
have come from particularly affluent or
privileged backgrounds I'll go back to
the case in Portland that sort of got
this whole investigation for us started
that defendant his name was Abdul Rahman
Nura I came from what is essentially a
middle class or lower middle-class
family in Saudi Arabia he was raised by
a single mother who was a schoolteacher
so that's not that the type of
individual you're thinking about when we
tend to think about you know Saudi
students who are studying in the US so
the scholarship program provides sort of
full tuition and other perks for
citizens from all backgrounds in Saudi
Arabia
what has the Saudi embassy had to say
about this I'm guessing you've spoken to
them or at least tried to yeah so for
the first the first handful of stories
that we had reported on we have
obviously reached out to the Saudi
embassy in Washington and the Saudi
consulate in Los Angeles was the entity
that had provided bail money for many of
the defendants here in Oregon so we
tried reaching out to individuals at the
consulate they're never heard anything
from them until two US senators both
from Oregon Ron Wayne and Jeff Merkley
introduced legislation in Congress as
sort of a direct response to the
findings in our reporting essentially
the you know the bills would seek to
punish Saudi Arabia if it was found that
they
that the government itself had portrayed
a role in helping some of these
individuals escape prosecution at that
point we started hearing from the Saudi
embassy in Washington and have heard
from them a couple of times since then
the gist of what we've been told and
it's mostly been pretty short structured
statements is that they have said that
the Saudi embassy as a policy will
provide bail money and legal services to
any citizen accused of crimes in the
United States who asked for help but
have categorically denied that they've
played any role whatsoever in
facilitating the departure of
individuals from the u.s. back to Saudi
Arabia now as soon as you're talking
about private planes unless these are
planes that are I don't know contracted
by the parents of these students doesn't
that directly imply that the Saudi
government is doing more than just bail
money and legal services I mean I think
that's a question best asked to federal
law enforcement investigators who sort
of are working with that theory right
now I think the more important thing to
kind of point out with the case of nura
who again was the Saudi national here in
Portland who killed a 15 year old girl
and a number of other cases here in
Oregon and then in other parts of the US
and in Canada a number of these students
as a condition for the release from jail
and they were bailed out were required
to turn their passports over to
authorities now that could have been the
Department of Homeland Security or the
for administrative officer in a
particular jurisdiction or other
authorities so a number of these
students have managed to leave the
United States and return to Saudi Arabia
without a passport
so the question there is how are they
able to travel when their travel
documents have been seized and I think
that's the you know I think that's the
particular detail more so than the
private plane or the prospect of a
private plane that really raises the
question with how the heck are these
guys getting out of the country if they
don't have a passport so you've laid out
what what the the initial sort of pieces
or steps in your investigation has been
in
you've talked to what's going on now and
what sort of your next step or focus in
all of this absolutely so this has
certainly gotten the attention of
senators Wyden and Merkley who have been
raising sort of a stink in Washington
the last couple of weeks or more more so
the last couple of months obviously
they've introduced bills into Congress
senator Wyden during who sits on the
Select Committee on Intelligence in the
Senate asked Christopher Rea the FBI
director and an open committee hearing a
month ago what the FBI knew about these
types of cases and asked if the FBI
could report back to him about any
involvement the Saudi government
government may have had in facilitating
the departure of these criminal
defendants or other ones senator Merkley
yesterday who's on the Foreign Relations
Committee was sort of asking the Trump
Trump nominee for ambassador to Saudi
Arabia about these cases and after weeks
of sort of raising questions it sounds
like a federal investigation or a kind
of probe is underway where a number of
agencies including Customs and Border
Protection the Department of Justice and
possibly the State Department are now
looking into these disappearances or at
least have told the you know senators
Wyden and Merkley that they're doing so
so the last thing I wanted to touch on
was you've looked at Saudi nationals and
and sort of what has happened there is
there any other country where there has
been a sort of similar disappearance of
people charged with crimes where it's
possible that the government was
involved in some way that's a really
great question and it's an important one
and it's one I think we hope to seek to
answer a little later down the line
certainly we've been asked the question
over and over again you know why are you
focusing sort of exclusively on Saudi
Arabia at this time and it's simply
because the first case we dealt with
and we thought we were dealing with just
one unusual incident here in Portland
involved a Saudi national and then once
we found that there were five here in
Oregon we decided we're gonna start
looking around the country and that's
something we're still doing now is
looking for other cases and we're
actually finding them and finding some
and other interesting things along the
way but you know clearly this hasn't
been sort of an attempt to single out
Saudi Arabia in particular but since
they are a close ally of the United
States because they don't have an
extradition treaty with us you know
we've been very intent on looking at
this you know particular country and
also because there's been a number of
questions sort of raised with in recent
months about you know the us-saudi
relations in the aftermath of the
killing of journalist Jamal khashoggi
the war in Yemen and other sort of
conduct by the Saudi Arabian government
abroad so that sort of fits into that
larger context as well but going back to
your question obviously we want to sort
of figure out who else you know from
from other parts of the world might be
participating in in similar ventures
really excellent work we've been
speaking with Shane Dickson Cavanaugh
who is a staff reporter with The
Oregonian in Portland we're going to
keep following the story Shane and I
appreciate you sharing it with our
audience Dave thanks so much for having
me on today